hey Vsauce Michael here if you were
driving in a car at the speed of light
and you turned on your headlights what
would happen would light be able to come
out or would your headlights just stay
dark or maybe light would come out but
it would just pool up inside the
headlight like a overflowing sink or
maybe the light would come out but at
twice the speed of light at its normal
speed plus the speed of your car no that
isn't sound right none of these answers
sound right because of course there is
no answer a car cannot travel at the
speed of light
nothing that has mass can but come on
you say there are things that can travel
at the speed of light things that have
no mass like photons
let's build a car out of light okay
let's take that suggestion because
imagining what it is like to be light
brings up a lot of questions about light
about why things are the way they are
and about whether or not we are real in
order to see what I mean
we need to talk about see the speed of
light it is constant as long as you
aren't accelerating you can move as fast
or slower in whatever direction you want
and you will still always see light
moving at light speed even when light
appears to slow down as it passes
through different materials the actual
photons themselves are still always
traveling at C they're just taking a
longer path which takes more time this
law always holds true because whenever
you move relative to other things your
measurements of them and their
measurements of you change when you move
everything not moving with you appears
to you to be shortened in length and to
be experiencing time more slowly whereas
to everything else it is you that these
changes happen to
these changes really happen just not
noticeably or measurably at the speeds
we usually travel at for example while
walking to your refrigerator for a snack
you will measure your fridge to be a 100
quadrillion of a meter nearer and
thinner than you would while it rest
with it you'll also notice that it
experiences time more slowly than you
each one of its seconds will be a 100
quadrillion of a second longer than
yours but your fridge will measure that
these transformations are happening to
you these are small numbers but at
speeds near the speed of light these
changes can be dramatic as I mentioned
in an earlier video to a particle racing
toward Earth at 99.999999 nein nein nein
nein nein nein 1% see the entire earth
would only appear to be 17 meters deep
our whole planet NOW with all of this in
mind let's take a look at headlights
being used by a stationary ship and one
that is moving at 99% the speed of light
the near Lightspeed ship would be
flattened in the direction of its travel
to us while a stationary one would not
as their headlights come on the light
coming from both ships travels at the
same rate the speed of a light source
doesn't push it faster
the moving ships velocity does however
give its head light energy in the
direction it's headed causing a blue
shift from the front and a red shift
from behind what's really cool though is
that this is just what we would see
floating in space at rest with the
stationary ship the crew of the fast
moving ship wouldn't see their beams
only gradually gaining on them like we
do they would see exactly what the crew
of the stationary ship sees light beams
rapidly fleeing their headlights at the
speed of light just as if they weren't
moving at all and here's why let's say
this distance is a light second the
distance light travels in one second
which is 299,792,458 meters now after
one of our seconds sure enough both
beams will have travelled a light second
but the crew of the moving ship measures
light speed to be the same as us but
how's that makes sense I mean light
hasn't trout
a light second from them yet no problem
you see what they measure a light second
to be is shorter than what we measure
and they wouldn't agree that a second
has passed yet either because of course
to us time is slower for them they count
one second finishing later than we do at
which point their light has indeed
traveled one of their light seconds from
them observers will often disagree about
time and space but those disagreements
will always conspire to make sure they
agree on one thing the speed of light it
is always the same for everyone but what
if you were traveling at the speed of
light well the only thing that could do
that would be a massless vehicle so fine
let's assume that we can build one such
a vehicle would travel with light light
would never even pull a tiny tiny bit
ahead of it no matter how short it
thought a metre was no matter how long
it thought a second was it would never
register light ever moving ahead of it
it would say that light was stationary
it would not agree that light traveled
at the speed of light right not really
you see at the speed of light there is
nothing to see not because there's
nothing to see but because there is
nothing to do any seen as we have seen
as an object's velocity approaches see
time for everything around it approaches
a standstill an object traveling very
very very very very very near the speed
of light could travel for billions of
our years before a single second passed
for it but a massless vehicle traveling
at the speed of light could travel
forever before a instant even began for
it it experiences no time and it would
have no time to do anything certainly no
time to turn on its headlights the
concept of time doesn't even really
apply a massless vehical couldn't even
have its headlights on before it hits
seed because an object with no mass must
always travel at sea such an object
would never have a before its origin its
journey and its destination are
simultaneous for it a billion light year
trip from a distant quasar might take a
boat on a billion years to us but it
literally takes no time for the photon
and to the photon the distance to us
from that quasar is literally nothing
photons are how we see how we know
anything about our place in the universe
and the energy they bring our planet
from the Sun is responsible for nearly
all life on Earth but despite that list
of accomplishments they don't think much
of themselves in fact as far as they're
concerned they don't even exist outside
observers of course see them and would
measure them to be moving along at the
speed of light with nothing passing and
gaining on them so if you were moving at
the speed of light you'd have to be
massless like a photon
you wouldn't notice anything because to
you there would be nothing and no time
to notice it
other people would see you doing nothing
and you would be unaware of yourself
you could never turn on headlights
because you would feel exactly like you
felt before you were conceived but why
is the speed of light what it is I mean
this is how far light travels in a
second could it also travel this far or
this far or this far could we conceive
of a universe where light traveled that
quickly yeah easily so then why is it
that the universe we live in is only one
of these ways why are the laws of
physics what they are instead of some
other way they could be well there are a
lot of theories but so far we're not
exactly sure how to test any of them
because we are stuck in this universe
and don't yet know how to create
universes of our own for experiments but
perhaps there is something we have yet
to discover that compels reality to be
this way and only this way or perhaps
nothing compels it to be this way but
instead there's a multi purse every
single possible universe exists some of
them collapsed immediately some of them
are empty and dark some of them involve
you watching this very video but earth
has two suns for those of you in that
universe watching that was probably very
confusing but I just said because your
earth does have two suns but the point
is the multiverse would be a pretty
elegant explanation
or maybe universe's are born inside
black holes universes whose physical
laws are only slightly different from
the universe that gave birth to it in
this way universes could replicate
according to natural selection universes
that are more fit for creating black
holes would then have more baby
universes making universes that support
black holes more common like maybe the
one that we're in and that's pretty
lucky because universes that support
black holes supports Suns and us or and
here's my favorite theory maybe we're
just living in a simulation and someone
or something else
programmed it up that sounds pretty
sci-fi sure but I like how Julian bikini
puts it in the pig that wants to be
eaten if you assume that at some point
in time virtual reality could become
good enough that even its own
inhabitants didn't know they were in a
simulation and if you assume that
creating such simulations would be way
easier than creating real
flesh-and-blood creatures that require
an entire universe of billions of years
well then it's pretty easy to conclude
that many many many many more simulated
fake beans could be created than real
ones say 999 fake ones for every one
real one well what's more likely that
you're part of the 0.1% that are real or
that you are part of the 99.9 percent
who think they're real but aren't
perhaps we live in a simulation created
by some other intelligent species John
Gribben however points out one possible
way to dismiss this idea irrational
numbers like the square root of 2 4 pi
these numbers don't end I mean they
contain a never ending never repeating
sequence of digits we
mean that whoever programmed this
universe could fit in all of say pi so
if in our tireless pursuit of
calculating more and more and more
digits of pi we ever run into an
endlessly repeating series or the end
that could be a pretty good sign that we
live in a simulation a universe that is
not real but so far we haven't found
that and we don't think that we will so
thank you irrational numbers for keeping
it real and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]